ايضا مشاهدينا في اخبار المتفرقه تغادر
هذه الايام كلاب الملكه الراحله اليزابيث
قصر باكينام الى الابد لتستبدل بكلاب من
نوع جاك روسول المحبوبه لدى الملك الجديد
شاروز الثالث والملكه كاملا بعد سنوات
طويله من بقاء الكلاب المفضله للملكه
الراحله في قصرها الشهير في باتنام ياتي
الكلبان
بلوبيل وبيف ومكانهما طبعا يحتلان هذا
المكان الجديد وهما المفضلان لدى الملك
الجديد تشارلز بالتاكيد ايضا مشاهدينا
ظهرا تشال في صوره التقطت لمناسبه الذكرى
الخامسه عشره على زواجهما عام 2020 وهما
يحملان الكلبين الذين ينتميان الى نوع
معروف وبره القصير وطاقته الكبيره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات